there have been no confirmed cases of
coronavirus in the UK for over a week
but that doesn't mean there's any room
for complacency containment is the key
so now covert 19 testing kits will be
given to district nurses and paramedics
so they can see suspected patients in
their own homes we're introducing
testing for the corona virus in people's
homes over the next few weeks so any
individual that we think may have come
into contact with corona virus after
assessment we will come to their home to
do the necessary nose and throat swabs
paramedics are already equipped with
face masks and protective equipment and
are using ambulances to transport
suspected patients but every time an
emergency vehicle is used it then has to
be deep cleaned taking that ambulance
out of operation the amice service is
under pressure around the country
primaries and Amblin staff are working
exceptionally hard this is only adding
to the pressure by producing this new
system I think will actually reduce that
the British government's strategy is so
far proving effective but London as a
major international transport hub is
vulnerable to an hour
this is where the home testing kits will
be first trialed before expanding the
scheme outside the cavity of course it
makes sense to test people in their own
homes the only way to contain a
potential epidemic is by quarantine but
there is some concern about adding to
the workloads
already under pressure frontline staff
the Queen's nursing Institute told us
consideration should be given to
employing nurses to specifically
undertake this work as the district
nursing service is under tremendous
pressure to deliver urgent care for
their patients every day general
practice nurses similarly will have full
clinics from which they cannot be
released without an impact on the people
they are caring for the number of covert
19 deaths outside China continues to
rise it is still very much a global
threat that's why every measure that can
be taken to stop the spread of this
deadly virus is being to our she's Joshi
Sky News